dieu pense ce qu'il veut moi j'ai saisi
l'art comme le reste je m'en fout en
fait c'est votre problème pas le mien
franchement ainsi reach t'adore c'est à
oui je sais mais je veux dire hier soir
c'est allé trop loin et si quelqu'un
pense que c'est pour moi je suis là tu
as police de messages que j'ai reçus
avec des gamins en pleurs à la suite des
propos de mathieu n'en donne notamment
effectivement de de romain lala romain
boyer j'ai reçu des messages de gamins
en pleurs alors on va rappeler le sujet
la brise rappel nous ce que tu disais
hier sur u10 est ce que je disais je dis
la même chose qu'à personnes qui étaient
là adorable d'ailleurs le médecin qui
était là bien sûr qu'à tellement
adorable qui ont échangé d'ailleurs
après nos mails na li no 10 à qui on
disait que il ya incontestablement une
souffrance cette souffrance elle existe
elle est majeure notamment chez les
jeunes elle est énorme et que
effectivement le port du masque y
contribuer mais j'ai immédiatement
a ajouté que c'était l'ensemble des
mesures qui posait problème et si
mathieu considère que c'est un problème
de gosses de riches c'est que le sol
riche que je vois ici c'est lui en fait
moi je suis désolé mais depuis quand
est-ce qu'on est loin de manquer de
respect de la sorte cette émission
j'adore mes succès merci mais que dire
si à chaque fois qu effectivement on ira
trop loin je marquerai le fait qu'on est
allé trop loin et hier soir mathieu tu
es allé trop loin pour moi je m'en fous
qu'est ce qui va m'arriver clark hommes
mais enfin mathieu si tu prends les
choses comme ça débrouille toi qu'est-ce
que l'écouté des coûts de fabrice ya un
an qu'il faut que j'apprenne quelque
chose la mort subite du jeu contents que
je sois là ce soir parce que j'avais un
doute comme vous avez cinq fois que tu
annonce que tu t'es dit le milieu
médiatique sont pures habitants voitures
viennent réellement non ça sert messi
part dont j'apprécie écouté hier fabrice
j'ai compris tu es là pour du buzz moi
je suis ravi fabrice du sort tu mets des
tweets
déjà leur pardon de la souffrance
j'adore sur la souffrance hier la phrase
que tu as dit exact c'est on met des
masques on les enlève le fait de les
mettre les enlève et les ans mais si
c'est ce que tu as dit que ces foules je
finirai les images j'ai fini par en bas
des normes chez les gens on se crée un
autre suicide énorme chez les jeunes
fabrice ça a été le confinement ça a été
tout ce tout ce qu vide totalement que
ce gène est au contraire en france
justement on a laissé les écoles
ouvertes pour que justement les mômes
souffre un petit peu moins de ces
conditions anxiogène mais comme
d'habitude voilà ce que tu fais et sans
ça que j'ai trouvé ça dégueulasse petit
à dieu tu utilise des arguments qui sont
faux pour venir nourrir tes théories à
toi sur le corps vide et ça si vraiment
tu avais tu avais connu moi mais des
gens moi qui se suicident fait des
tentatives de suicide
mais tes théories sur le colis de qu'on
connaît tous ce que tu auras tu repars à
méreau par métier m'entraîne dur y aura
pas de moi il reste est en fait et
ensuite ce que je te dis hier quand je
te dis que c'est des problèmes de riche
tu n'as pas écouter les preuves de
riches ça fait des semaines que tu as
sur ce plateau pour nous expliquer il
tourne le dos et en plus tu n'es pas
éduqués pour lui expliquer qu
effectivement whaou on doit prendre un
café de bourdes à prendre un café à 6
c'est très grave alors moi je tenais des
chiffres aussi puisque tu penses que
justement c'est très grave le masque et
kako du masque tout le monde se suicider
bien moi ce que je vais te dire quand la
sécu pas du tout les gens les gens en
afrique ce que tu es d'hier les jours
notre hygiène à tétouan et déchiffre les
gens en afrique il n'ya pas de vaccin
donc je t'ai année des chiffres le mali
6 % des gens sont vaccinés le sénégal 10
ça te parle ça tu crois que ces gens eux
se posent la question de savoir si
enlevé lé masque leur maître aller boire
un café d'un bras si c'est compliqué tu
peux regarder suppose alors à tous
autour de toi on va essayer d'en
uniquement de voilà de là où tu es à me
devais te dire cyril oui moi je pense
que ce qui se passe c'est la chose
suivante on a vécu une année et demi
deux ans terrible avec des familles qui
se sont divisés on est une société qui
s'est fracturé pan de dire
définitivement je pense même et si un
truc que je vais pas faire c'est
répondre à mathieu je vais dire pourquoi
pas apprendre à mathieu serait mathieu
comment faire m'agresser
mais tout le show c'est un mauvais fait
d'autre a brillé ce dernier les claques
qui porte une robe du sort du battu les
clippers était mal éclairé pas né mais
c'est vrai
qu'elle était venue tu fais du boulevard
laisse j'ai compris en fait tu m'as fait
venir juste pour instrumentaliser les
faire de l'audience et au hockey sers
toi de moi mais non plus bien mignon
alors je suis à la réunion continue et
non mais la défense il coutume de moi
non mais dis moi ce que tu as lui dire
sur ces chine en moi j'ai rien à dire je
suis désolé quand on prend les choses
comme ça j'ai rien de dire cyrine alors
avancé de fabrice des cons et fatma la
vie tchô hier le médecin a dit un peu
d'humilité tu as vu ce que tu lui a
répondu j'étais le premier à dire
scientifiquement j'étais le premier à
dire aux médecins j'étais première
contre le paços vaccinale j'étais le
premier 2 contre le vaccin mais c'est
formidable
personne ne sait que dans le monde sur 7
milliards il ya un génie qui savait sur
l humilité toi est ce que tu as à
l'humidité fabrice di vizio a dit
beaucoup de vérité j'ai aussi beaucoup
de conneries et les médecins alors mais
vous n'avez rien dit ben c'est bien
quand on dit rien on prend pas de la
drogue pour toi mais tu sais quoi mavuba
moi quand je sais pas si j'ai une fuite
d'eau tout le monde a applaudi les six
jeunes traînent le pas de moi la
boulange et si j'ai appris que je
demande à
monsieur andré taymans vous répéter
comme ça intéresse pas mais qu'est ce
que
c'est juste une mode plus je suis pas de
votre avis à nos à graz est un perroquet
mais a décoincé bout qui est agacé ceni
fabrice et moi qui le dit et qu'on vous
savez quand même ce que j'ai aimé
repasser oui je m'excuse mais j'ai une
vie de famille quand même ça vous parle
d'une des familles ou pas en quoi j'ai
une vie de famille c'est que quand je
viens ici oui c'est sûr ma vie de
famille que je prends le temps je dors
peu près trois heures par nuit je dirais
tu gères parce que depuis un an et demi
j'accompagne ma souffrance des gens amap
fun mesure t'inquiète pas l'humilité
j'en suis rempli mathieu contrairement à
toi ça c'est pas de problème fait rire
parce que depuis tout à l'heure moi ce
que je note c'est quelqu'un qui vienne
donner des leçons moi je suis ici pour
dire écoute on doit pouvoir réussir à
s'entendre dans un esprit de
réconciliation alors que c'est ce dont
le monde a besoin et dont l'absence a
société a besoin mais regarde pas quand
tu crois que les normes et fabrice
j'ai à dire t'intéresse ou alors je vais
te laisser parler parce qu'on a besoin
d'une tribune tu as besoin d'exister
avant moi mais ça fait un nom tu sais ce
que tu aimes algérie tu étais un petit
chien qui est inconnu ou shirato kobe
thoune a commencé rôle des professeurs
vous faisons est devenu une star et
écluses bien à ça tu passes ton temps à
faire souffler prato télé durant
ces mois cadre et une tribune laisse
parler les jambes à rennes c'est devenu
le roi de manhatan face à bah oui
j'aimais bien fabrice non j'ai rien à
dire c'est bon non mais fabrice jeannet
c'est bon mais j'aime la toile ça
termine quand l'émission non moi
j'aimerais que tu lui explique fabrice
j'aimerais que tu ne
l'ès pas parlé non mais je vais te dire
la rue n'a pensé c'est que mathieu
manifestement un problème un problème je
sais pas ce qu'il est avec ce qu vide je
respecte ça parfaitement manifestement
qui a une peur bleue je sais pas quelle
est ta vie et je suis vraiment désolé
pour par martens et je ne veux surtout
pas aggraver sa blessure donc deux peur
d'aggraver sa blessure tu sais lire moi
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour toi et
depardieu fabrice excuse moi de peur
d'aggraver sa blessure et ne souhaitant
absolument pas trop désagréable et la
manière dont tu te comportes
effectivement témoin d'une grande
souffrance que je respecte parfaitement
mathieu présente mais moi ce qui
m'interesse voiture c'est d'accompagner
la souffrance des gens en général et des
enfants en particulier celle là même que
tu a nié hier soir et les réseaux
sociaux mathieu s'y sont pas trompés ils
ont vu la séquence à l'horizon venez
vous l'avions vu j'ai vu ce que dire de
toi
attention vers mathieu si ça fait
plaisir de ma tach effet le site a
besoin d'exister en faisant ça fait le
jeu tu en prime le cas l'une d'eux a
besoin de moi plus invaincu erdre et le
2 paris moi j'aimerais qu'ils
conviennent c'est le deuxième volet sur
tout ce que tu as dit pendant la
pandémie et mais on s'en servir explique
à mathieu tout ce que tu as dit mais je
dirais moi j'ai rien dit kate et moi la
différence la différence est vrai des
landes j'ai dit que c'est vrai mais je
n'ai jamais dit je n'ai toujours dit ne
me croyez pas ici quand on disait que le
variant brésilien était beaucoup plus
létal je vous ai dit ne me croyez pas
allez voir c'est vous avez fait peur les
uns et les autres même toit à cyril vous
avez tous je reconnais cependant que tu
as été l'année dernière l'homme du débat
c'est un peu moins vrai cette année mais
c'est la vie c'est comme ça mais la
dernière tu fais tes valises et tu as
été l'homme du débat l'année dernière et
en avoir on a pu voir une tribune pour
exprimer non pas des opinions
divergentes mais pour exprimer des faits
je suis toujours venu dans cette
émission et dans les autres avec des
faits hier quand je parle mathieu du
suicide des enfants c'est pas mes
chiffres et quand tu dis que c'est des
problèmes de riches et bien si tu n'as
pas lu non je veux dire que c'est de
parler des masques les prem de rire je
ne défend le généreux m tu es tellement
véhément que tu n'écoutes tu es
tellement blessée que tu n'écoutes bien
réclamer sa 112 est d ailleurs toute la
mort de rené m'a miné si tu connais ma
vie comme du collège hubert donc on
connaît rien puisque je n'ai pas ma vie
sans mathieu
je n'en tire vraiment une vie
mais bon tu sais si j'ai maintenant je
suis venu pour que tu te foutent de ma
gueule ça fait plaisir en fait d'abord
qui m'a fait le clown qui du tout venant
maintenant simplement je veux dire moi
on m'a dit quand je suis en plateau bon
alors nous dire comme m'a dit fais gaffe
quand même à peine un peu à la paix
parce qu'il ya des messages de haine sur
les réseaux sociaux moi j'appelle à rien
à part est mon manager m'a dit moi aussi
alors moi j'appelle à rien merci mathieu
son compère la gueule c'est son problème
les français reconnaîtront voici l'heure
quand même salle de la muse ça le fait
rire de nouveau la question de la
souffrance des enfants de nexar
ken markgraf et hoëdic la souffrance des
enfants de la réception de le dire je
t'ai dit hier quand tu as dit oui le
problème c'est qu'on met les masses pour
les zones est bon mais les mars on les
enlève je t'ai dit que le problème des
mass media
voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà on met
lass et continue la séquence d'hier mais
non je m'en fous je n'avais pas on la
sait avoir n'a pas payé c'est payant
mais non du sang s'il vous plaît
confinement le couvre-feu tout c'est
l'ensemble finalement des choses qui a
abandonné contribué un sentiment de mal
être de la population qu'il ne faut pas
négliger ce drame on a des caprices de
riz
commence à nantes en date en danger
des non-dits battue c'est sa démarche de
mme hélène mathieu répéter sans parler
des masques ou pas est ce que tu dis
quoi je parle et inquiète par dessus de
maintien de quoi je parlais ils me tuent
le marquoir conneries parle de suicide
tu dis sentiment de mal être mathieu de
quoi que les gens qui en sentiment de
malaise
oui aux enchères du fer en fait je veux
savoir
en fait c'est en fait c'est une manie
dès qu'on n'est pas d'accord avec toi tu
quittes le plateau je misais une manille
mais quittent pas leur ceinture viendra
après demain c'est la bonne nouvelle non
fabrice de lui des explications ce que
tu aller j'y vais mais je m'en fous de
mathieu il est personne ce vrai ces
personnes seraient rien au salaire qu'il
a vous rigolez sur la pandémie depuis un
an depuis un an ça vous fait rire dans
toute l'ue à nantes lui qui m'a pas ce
que je vais on a tous je veux dire que
tu es mathieu je vais te dire tu es un
bobo qui effectivement pour toi le
confinement et tout ça les masques parce
que tu parles des massues bien les mac
s'imprègne de riches mais le masque tu
ne portes pas tu lui est imposé à ton
public pendant des mois le masque et toi
tu disserte sur le masque que tu n'as
jamais porté ici ni vexé ni
l'affectionné [ __ ] mais c'est petit
même si c'est pas
parce que tu es ma bataille où tu dis
mais mais on attend mais quand est ce
que vous allez contenter l'un et l'autre
chargeons pc/mac de passe etc et grave
c'est la forme grave
c'est ça qui est grave alors ma revanche
et je te passe si je n'ai pas de copine
n'est que des bac c'est n'est fait il ne
t'arrivera rien marriott accor y est ou
du matelas pour jour et spécialistes
locaux vides à la gdd chu de besançon
césar maintenant que mature n'atteignait
que son ego allez un plan comme mature
et qui me regarde tu vois c'est ça ton
problème mais voilà c'est pour toi tout
est chaud tu es un mec moindre des
choses le comics la télé réalité pour
toi mais tu es toi qui lis alors quand
même parlons des formes graves mathieu
allez vas-y mais je voulais dans la
semaine du 28 au 28 février au 6 mars
par exemple sont entrées par jour
quatre-vingt-dix-sept personnes en soins
critiques est ce que tu peux me donner
mathieu la proportion de non vaccinés
parmi ces chiffres alors déjà avant ce
chiffre là non tu fais partie tu as mis
en attente
déjà le jeu passionnant mais tu as déjà
une telle crise à la zemmour tu arrives
avec un chiffre que personne ne peut
vérifier l'adresse 27 d'artistes pour
faire des gens de besançon 10 et après
tu développes ton raisonnement mathieu
mais déjà ce chic et ses 12 matches la
dernière fois vêtue du massachusetts ali
faisait quinze links et 15 pages en
anglais tu n'es pas l'anglais alors
qu'étant du coup sur coup en fait ça
vous amuse mais ça vous amuse
qu'après une question répondant et ça
vous amuse très bien les gens des
animations ça vous amuse énorme et les
gens peuvent plus accéder aux soins
sabre est la muse et ça vous a abusé
pendant quelques mois le pass vaccinale
c'était bien mais toi tu es bien content
le vérifier de cba locaux vides reviens
tu as par bos à nouveau
devant la télé quand dias préfet s'est
petit à petit je vais te dire le cas
vous avez choisi vos matthieu cheruy moi
j'ai pas besoin tafer n'ont pas besoin
d'être fait mathieu j'ai pas besoin
d'être ici qu'est ce qu'on fait là
qu'est ce que vous faites là parce que
dans un esprit novena vocation parce que
ce que je veux être jura dole fabrice
jusqu'au bout vous aurez jusqu'au bout
du bout c'est l'homme de la huret de la
paix jusqu'au bout du bout mathieu mais
moi aussi non tu es tout sauf ça parce
que en l'occurrence si on peut reprendre
le débat sur le fond je vais te dire
mathieu j'ai de la peine pour toi tu
sais pourquoi corps j'aide à peine pour
toi mais si poussée pourquoi il parce
que tu es beaucoup percée à l'idée que
le vaccin ne protège et ben alors remets
mes chiffres
importants je m'étais donné les chiffres
a dit il est en réanimation il y avait
26 3% de da proportion qui était pas
vacciner ça veut dire que tu as 70% des
gens aujourd'hui rien n'est sûr qu'ils
sont vaccinés mathieu c'est les chiffres
de la drees c'est pas les miens dans
l'est dans les décès tu as 31% le
problème c'est que vous ne voulez pas
les entendre ces chiffres j'ai beau les
assumer tout le monde est vacciné c'est
normal c'est en valeur absolue
évidemment tu dis est évident et une à
nort absolue oui un peu de mathématiques
on ne veut pas les entendre ces chiffres
mais qu'est ce qui te fait dire explique
mans juste quelque chose et là je te
pose la question très sincèrement
explique moi juste pourquoi le monde
entier où quelques personnes seulement
le monde ne comprend pas ce que toi tu
as bail non c'est pas vrai mathieu saute
alors comment se fait-il de génie nous
sentir être un vrai dire un truc
attention j'ai trouvé une révélation oui
oui écoute bien voilà une vie aux heures
d'été pmp oui si tu sortais oui tu
verrais qu'en fait mon avis comme tu dis
c'est pas mon avis en fait tu verrais
cap le plus en plus de voix qui
s'élèvent pour quand même remettre en
question la vaccination les pays qu'ils
abandonnent tu vois bien qu'à plein de
pays qu'ils abandonnent - mais au-delà
de ça à mathieu je m'en fiche en réalité
ce que je veux dire c'est que moi en soi
que les gens se fassent vacciner si l'on
en a envie quand quoi ça me poserait
problème pourquoi tu voudrais que
j'empêche des gens de se faire vacciner
au nom de quoi pourquoi les empêcherait
de faire et ce n'est plus et mathieu moi
je m'en fiche régence à vacciner moi
simplement mais je m'en fiche
complètement simplement ce que je ne
veux pas je peux pas la vaccination je
te parle du pass jusqu'ici je me suis
toujours battu contre les mesures autour
de la vaccination ici est ce que vous
m'avez entendu déjà dire que la
vaccination était un problème majeur
tuer les gens des gens le disent et sans
doute à raison moi je suis toujours
resté dans la mesure à ce sujet j'ai
toujours mis en cause les mesures autour
de la vaccination et notamment les
passes sanitaires les passes vaccinaux
et je suis toujours être comme de la
mesure pour dire ici je vous ai dit que
la vaccination n'était pas la baguette
magique quand vous vous réjouissiez de
la baguette magique israélienne on avait
tous revit je vous ai dit les gars à mon
avis vous allez un peu vite la
vaccination est un outil et c'est la
phrase qui a été employée ici hier soir
un outil si vous qui en avez fait une
nouvelle religion j'y peux rien mathieu
si aujourd'hui tu es très déçu à cause
des nouvelles religions j'ai parfois
d'essayer tous les vaccins raffole
jamais les combinois écoute moi j'y peux
rien c'est quelles que soient les
vérités que l'on amène elle te dérange
au point d'avoir une espèce de biais
cognitifs qui t'empêche de les voir je
suis désolé situe à ce point peur du coc
vide tu ne risques rien mathieu tu es
jeune en bonne santé tu ne risques rien
de compétences et déguster tout
qu'est-ce que tu connais mon second
dossier médical on affine encore une
fois tu parles sans sa place et tous nos
problèmes a tué tout emporté monsieur
laisse moi finir calme toi et laisse moi
finir 94 % des gens qui seraient
décédées ont plus de 60 ans mais tu vois
comment vous tue discuter parce que
c'est un monologue de seafrance empêcher
la naissance pas
mais bon maintenant 1 494 pour cent des
décès sont des gens de plus de 60 ans
d'accord il ya tension parmi ces décès
le motif principal du covan ne
représentait que 60% ce que je vais
essayer de vous dire c'est que vous
n'entendez pas de choix mathieu ton
premier tube complètement imperméable à
toute idée de raisonnement la raison a
complètement janvier a disparu et une
voix bien tu es de l'incarnation nom de
la foi pas de la raison alors tu la fois
dans le vaccin et quand j'essaye de
débattre parce que des bâtons alors date
11 ans je vais répondre avec toi avec un
cas concret voilà qui s'est blessé alors
la soirée pour mathis devrait fournir
enfin les cas concrets mais je peux t'on
jamais plaint que les normes et dans sa
capitale ottomane et des cas concrets
avec ce n'est pas toi rémy dès gens
qu'elles sont cas concrets et pacifique
mardi matin bien moi allions pas là j'ai
une amie voilà qui est un cancer qui a
dû se faire opérer on lui dit on est
désolé on va devoir différer cette
opération parce qu'il y a des gens qui
sont réanimation les gens qui est en
réanimation pour la grande majorité-- ça
situe le need u man ne sais pas je n'en
pensais signer n'était pas même à les
vacciner mais mathieu coupe à turin je
suis venu maintenant mais comme il ya
vraiment eu les yeux de farmer qui peut
contester des chiffres que les médecins
eux-mêmes contrainte shepard intéresse
mais nommée donc que les chiffres ne
sont pas ta faveur et intéresse pas mais
donnez moi des chiffres mais les
médecins raté tu as voilà tu sais pas
mais du soir ils t'ont fait pas non plus
ça change d'ambiance on l'avait mais
s'est montré ni tes choix voilà bien une
marine le pen et voilà c'est ça ton
faudra mais c'est ce à quoi je peux
contribuer toi aussi battu l'algérien
vire moi je crois des médecins je crois
des médecins mais je suis peut-être zen
je suis peut-être met des je crois en
l'homme de l'art un médecin ça fait 16
ans 19 ans d'études et bêtement comme je
ne sais pas parce que tu as raison donc
comme je n'ai pas te laisse enfin je dis
bon sens ne vaut il mieux le sens de mon
bon sens et d'écouter un médecin et
c'est pas départ mais derrière tu
écoutes lequel quand on n'est pas que le
clown a du bon sens ok tu n'as pas de
culture qui déborde en écoute écoute
quel médecin à bord d'un véhicule a
autant d'avis alors tu écoutes les
médecins soient chloroquine ces coquines
ça marche alors ce qui est sûr c'est que
ça marche ça marche parfois au king's
collège pas médecin mais comment ça
démarre ya des médecins qui est ce que
ça marche donc auquel tu fais confiance
mais surtout choisi mais alors je
commente choisi eh bien je vais te dire
je préfère un mauvais généralistes qu'un
avocat du chanteur d'assurance et alban
faire sur un même
toit la firme train de dire barre mais
c'est que même chez les médecins les
avis divergent énormément oui mais vaut
mieux vaut mieux des médecins qui
s'engueulent entre eux si tu veux pas
paraître chose qui connaissent qu'un
avocat qu'il a voulu tourner dans
médecins et médecins commencent à
choisir quel médecin alors équipe multi
écrans munichois chose va pas redorer la
grande grande majorité des médecins
étaient pour la vaccination et étaient
du même côté mathieu professeur qui est
sorti du lot parce que j'ai un peu comme
toi et les showman des ruines à l'emploi
mais c'est passé le panneau sera ouvert
du tout tu boca la même rue pauline ado
moi mathieu web un rapport à août n'a
jamais été contre la vaccination bien
sûr il a jamais dit que je suis et
j'aime bien ton niveau est tellement bas
tu as un niveau tellement mauvais quand
tu ne sais même pas qui a dit quoi merci
il a jamais répondu sur la vaccination
est venu ksiri lui lançant le braille ne
répondait pas de vaccination prévue
mais ta tête
mais tu fais pas mon garçon adacore
salle kerry micks que jamais a dit si
franchement ça franchement ici tout est
chaud
chaud sur la souffrance des gens
mais c'est pas écrit brice n'ont pas
tort
juste un détail sur les médecins mathieu
je vais t'apprendre un truc le mépris
que tu as volé mais dites-moi écoute moi
c'est pas grave pas grave pas grave
finir fait tellement s'étonnerait
presque jonction méprisable mathieu tu
es tellement au dessus du lot tu sais
tout quelle chance tu as des badges et
non je ne sais quelle chance et ce même
au médecin tu leur donnes ne sont pas
bien des gens si tu allais est un génie
en fait je vous raconte pas la gueule
enfin non non
tout va et puisque
tu l'as eu plein la gueule à ce que je
cherche à te dire mathieu c'est que tu
vois il ya une erreur fondatrice non je
ne sais rien la différence entre toi et
moi que se situe à un niveau moins ici
sur ce plateau j'ai toujours dit ne me
fait pas confiance jamais non mathieu
cyr il a toujours dit je crois fabrice
gygi non surtout pas on ne me croit pas
bon d'accord je veux dire non mais je te
demande pas de me croire le problème
c'est que quand je t'amène des données
objectives comme l'adresse tout à coup
ça t'intéresse maintenant je te crois
pas tu ne reconnais pas d'avoir la
vérité mais non mais tu ne crois pas
mais tu peux vérifier mathieu jacques
ses succès il ya un truc qui s'appelle
le cerveau tu peux l'utiliser de temps
en temps tu as le droit
petite mention tour excusez moi petite
mention pour le public vous vous comme
ou là vous croyez ou la bande de cons là
rien savoir la les minables mais tu te
rends compte pourquoi tu passes devant
un million de téléspectateurs mathieu de
2,2 des gens dangereux encore mieux tu
te rends compte que tu passes 2 millions
10 mois mathieu j'ai une question est
posée le rapport d'enquêté sénatoriale
c'est pas moi qui devais écrire je te
rassure tu l'as lu leur accordant oui tu
sais le sénat la chambre basse pour nous
c'est le truc qui sert à des luttes où
tu ne l'as pas lui a pas du bas tu sais
quoi ouais on va faire un ding qu il lit
ah non non tu ne dis pas non ok nous
intéresse pas de savoir en fait donc
savoir c'est une question intéressante
est ce que je suis venu pour débattre et
m'en prendre plein la gueule et faire du
show mais fabrice vial chad reed tu
viens parce que fabrice mais je vais
essayer un pour faire du show tu viens
toujours existé tu es le briquet à sa
retraite ça t'amuse tu fais des entrées
et des sorties l'agent blessé la review
tu aimes par les sermons et bravo tu
fais très bien dès mercredi que l'année
dernière thé des premiers chroniqueurs
médecins à l'avenir du comics je termine
en disant ashrae termine
que en fait ce que font ce match que de
moi je m'en tamponne la cacahuète la
cacahouète gelée de ou la laine on a les
deux je pense que c'est bien de dire les
deux breaks et caouette merci pour cette
précision ainsi simplement bien souvent
la mutu voix en fait je peux encore
mathieu à mon enfance je sais la
verticale vraiment je plains mathieu
parce que quand tu as autant de
véhémence à la garde de quelqu'un est
versée ça traduit comme une souffrance
on connaît une souffrance est et par où
les deux roues les deux masses ou les
deux c'est possible mais tu vois moi
j'ai pas l'intention de te juger donc
j'ai partir du double juge statue pas
dire que je finis la deskjet je suis un
tête à queue je connais rien secteur
jugent tout le monde à te prend pour un
génie aura bien un char de
rotation des téléspectateurs des mois
jusqu'aux fêtes je viens pas si vide
quand je viens ici je viens quand je
viens ici j'ai pas pour mathieu pour les
uns et les autres cherchent à écouter
quelqu'un perd son titre pendant une
heure et demie je m'en fiche que tu fais
à chaque fois fait si tu veux très bien
mais moi tu vois ce que je viens c'est
devant les spectateurs aux
téléspectateurs ce soir je dis quoi
alors je dis allez voir les chiffres de
la drees il ya ainsi quiconque notable
c'est des données officielles allez voir
effectivement sur la semaine du 21 au 27
février allez voir sur la semaine du 28
février au 6 mars et vous allez voir que
ben quand on vous dit que le vaccin
protège des formes graves et bien vous
avez le droit d'interroger ça eh bien
moi je leur dis allez voir aux médecins
une exception les avocats à l'ego
surdimensionné existait dit quelque
chose on est d'accord on est là merci
mathieu mais n'allez surtout pas voir
votre avocat mais allez réfléchir par
vous même ne laissez personne vous
piquez la réflexion à mener c'est pour
rire et faire 16 ans d'études pour leur
design chose cette saison c'est un
spécialiste n'importe pas ce qu'ils ont
construit dix ans bien sûr c'est cette
ombre swans et moi on est mal va ne les
ont pas c'est énorme ça parce que tu
connais que des médecins qui ont doublé
près de moi reina mais c'est déjà énorme
ces derniers temps aux français qui nous
regarde je voudrais vraiment dire ceci
ne croyer ni les uns ni les autres ni
les uns ni les autres faites vous votre
propre opinion mais comment il fait nous
sommes un médecin ils sont bas mais des
rameaux exemple moi excuse moi vous avez
des données sont-elles anarchique non à
la voir le site de fabrice di vizio
n'allez pas voir le site complotistes
que sais-je allez vous voulez arriver en
soucier des solutions à aller voir les
données santé publique france allait
voir les données de la drees aller les
voir aller les voir ne regardez pas
mathieu ou moi on sait les gens ne
seront pas les lire sur un métier non
mais mathias jamais à son métier savent
lire des chiffres j'avais dit
s'adressant à mme excuse moi tu sais
mathieu a dit fort sous toit et moi je
sais je suis content un génie de detroit
une mauvaise en forme non
non je ne prends pas les français pour
des imbéciles
c'est tout et que les français ont une
intelligence suffisante pour aller se
faire eux mêmes tu sais quoi 4
j'ai une question à vous poser judo si
vous avez devant vous des enveloppes est
ce que vous vous voulez bien sûr partir
du bon sens tout les dunes ou beau crier
tous les deux ou bien est ce que vous
voulez dire c'est bien sûr harry parce
que fabrice était venu dans un dans un
souci d'apaisement la même tous pareils
moi je sors mon enveloppe alors je
digère fabrice que je reconnais que tu
travailles tu es intelligent après voilà
je suis pas d'accord avec toi je pense
que tu dis déjà dans l'enveloppé il ya
je te pardonne ouais uni comme boucle à
eau ni comme boucle un jeu je ne parle
pas l'arabe mais j'imagine que c'est pas
très sympathique j'ai mis je te pardonne
fabrice je serais ravi d'aller déjeuner
avec toi fabrice un jour à pied
sans caméra c'est sa caméra quand tu me
mathieu et ben voilà il discussions
qu'on a eues hors plateaux sont
particulièrement intéressants et je
tenais sincèrement caméra également face
à une caméra devient le showman verbe à
se bouffer q c'est l'inversé